on the tarmac at kabul airport images
which so clearly define an american
defeat
wearing american kit most with american
weapons this is america's enemy now back
in charge
this is a man who for 10 years has been
a faceless voice of the taliban in
hiding a man who denies bin laden was
responsible for 9 11.
now leading the celebrations for what
they are calling afghanistan's
independence day
me
[Applause]
across the sprawling airport our cameras
filmed what's left of military equipment
abandoned when the afghan government
collapsed
the americans had hastily intentionally
damaged what they could as they withdrew
in washington the president appeared to
declare a mission accomplished he was
though claiming a success in achieving a
retreat
the extraordinary success of this
mission was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals it was
again a defense of his decision to bring
this war to an end i was not going to
extend this forever war
and i was not extending a forever exit
for terrorists there was this warning
and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
as commander-in-chief
i firmly believe the best path to guard
our safety and our security lies in a
tough
unforgiving targeted precise strategy
that goes after terror where it is the
day
not where it was two decades ago
the president can of course for now
successfully claim that this so-called
forever war is over but it is the legacy
which will follow him the impact it's
had on allies the chaos has cost them
politically the message it sends to
russia and china about american
priorities and then of course the
all-important reaction of the american
people they wanted this war finished but
it's the way it was brought to an end
people and equipment left behind
and the enemy and terrorists emboldened
south of kabul in the city of cost
taliban supporters with coffins
representing the west a message from
them but may be a reflection too of a
shift in western foreign policy no
longer able or willing to intervene mark
stone sky news in washington